Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Hitogotchi
I don't know if I'm pronouncing that right, but I didn't pronounce Tamagotchi either
which is good segway into what I was gonna talk about.
High five, me! (High five) Great job, me!
I'm the king of talking to myself alone, oh God...
Anyway, so if you guys remember Tamagotchis
They were these little things that you had on a key-chain...
Insert graphic of Tamagotchi
And you would take care of this Tamagotchi that I'm gonna make really hard to animate
...later...
Where is it?
(regretful laugh)
If you remember a Tamagotchi, they were like a hit, for like a few years
and some people still have them to this day
I know there's some people in the comments right now
that are still taking care of their Tamagotchi.
But what they were - they were pets
that you... kept around
And it was like, it was like, it was like
you bought a key-chain of responsibility
You bought something that you had to keep alive
And it was very hard to keep ali-
It was very easy to let it die
and then you'd be sad
so it was a little ball of sadness
and a little bit of happiness
that you carried around with you.
It's a ticking time bomb of disappointment
is basically what that is.
But it was fun!
maybe...
But this is "Hitogotchi"
which is supposed to be the inverse of Tamagotchi
where you...
or I...
...am the Tamagotchi.
I don't know. Helloooo!
(Reading onscreen text) [Girl] "Um... hello!"
"I'm the person assigned to take care of... a monster?"
Ahn... is that me?
Is that who I am?
[Girl] "Is this the right house?"
(Deep, raspy voice) Leave! Leave AND NEVER RETURN
YOU COME AND FOUND THE MONSTER!
NOW NEVER GO BACK!
TELL EVERYONE, THAT HE IS A SCREAMING IDIOT!
WITH A STUPID RED HAIR!
[Gril] "Hey! That's kind of rude."
Well, I am a monster so there you have it.
[Girl] "Wait a minute, you're..."
[Narration] "The girl stares your face for an awkward amount of time"
I know! I'm blazingly handsome
It's a burden that I have to bear.
[Girl] "Yeah! You're the one!"
"Oh, um, let me introduce myself."
"My name is Nadine, and I will be your personal caretaker for the week."
"This will be my first time taking care of a non-human, so I hope we can get along!"
[Mark] You shoul-... (Raspy voice) YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE COME HERE! YOU SHOULD- I THOUGHT I WARNED YOU!
I thought this-- I thought the posters of my face outside the walls
were enough to ward anybody away.
YOU SHOULDN'T HAVE COME HERE!
[Nadine] "Now, now, no need to be rude to someone you just met."
"Well then, I'll be sorting my things upstairs for a little while, I'll see you in a bit."
O-Okay.
[Narration] "Nadine brings her luggage as she goes up the stairs."
[Nadine] "So! What we do our first day together?"
[Mark] Eat, play, sleep, talk?
Um... only so long as to get to eat you!
Uh... I guess we could talk...?
[Nadine] "So... where's your family?"
[Mark] I-I-I... ate... I ate them.
I... I kinda ate them.
I might of a little bit ate them.
[Nadine] "Ate them?" (deep, guttural laugh)
"That's funny."
[Narration] "You spent time talking with Nadine"
[Nadine] "Time for you to sleep! I cant wait for tomorrow."
[Narration] "You had a well deserved rest."
[Mark] Oh! Shit!
[Ominous voice] "You're doing better than last time."
[Mark] What is that supposed to mean?!
[Nadine] "Morning! What should we do today?"
[Mark] Eaaaat?
[Narration] "The menu for today is... nothing."
[Nadine] "I'm sorry, the agency didn't give me any food for today..."
[Mark] I'LL "EAT" YOU INSTEAD!
[Nadine] "Eh...? Wh- What are you saying?"
[Mark] Why are you happy about that?
NO, DON'T GET THE WRONG IDEAS HERE!
[Narration] "What do you have on your mind?"
[Mark] Uhhh...
Play?
[Narration] "Nadine brought a maracas."
[Nadine] "Shake shake shake!"
[Mark] You su- You suc- Oh, God I'm such an asshole!
But I am a monster!
"You suck at your job!"
[Nadine] "I'm doing what I can!"
[Narration] "You shook the maracas."
[Nadine] "Hey, um... how am I doing as your caretaker?"
[Mark] Oh, geez! Oh, man!
Well you didn't feed me,
so if I had to a- give any answer, it'd probably be...
...meh...
I mean, you brought maracas, and I do like maracas, so...
So-so.
[Nadine] "Really? Thanks."
"I'll do my best for the rest of the week."
[Ominous voice] "Blood... doesn't that girl have it...?"
"I wonder how it tastes..."
[Mark] Oh, geez! Oh, geez!
OH, GEEZ!
Is - Is - Are these options gonna do
what I think they're gonna do?
(exhales reluctantly)
"Kill?"
"Kill her?"
[Nadine] "Oh, do you need something?"
[Ominous voice] "Just like the other ones?"
"BE DONE WITH IT."
[Nadine] "What is it?"
[Mark] I don't know what I expected...
[Ominous voice] "MONSTERS CAN'T CHANGE."
"YOU NEVER LEARN."
[Mark] Oh, shit! Well I - I guess that's it, then!
WELL
FUCKERNUT
I DONE-DID A GOOF.
I GOOFED REAL HARD,
I DID BAD,
You guys are all disappointed in me,
but don't worry!
I'm gonna blast through this with expert-
something-or-other.
[Nadine] "Hello!"
[Mark] Hello!
It is the right house! Indeed, welcome!
Come on in!
[Nadine] "Ah, good! I thought I went to the wrong place for a second, there."
"Wait a minute, you're..."
[Narration] "The girl stares at your face..."
[Nadine] "You're the one..."
"My first time taking care of a non-human..."
[Mark] ...Sure we will!
We're gonna get along great!
[Nadine] "Glad you think that too."
"I'll be sorting my things upstairs for a little while."
[Mark] See you in a bit!
[Nadine] "...So! What should we do?"
[Mark] Oh! We should play!
...brought a ball!?
[Narration] "She threw it."
[Nadine] "Fetch!"
[Mark] Well, I'm not a dog!
[Nadine] "Ahaha, sorry."
"I'm not sure about what things a non-human would want."
[Narration] "You played along with her for a bit."
[Nadine] "Time for you to sleep! I can't wait for tomorrow!"
[Ominous voice] "Blood..."
[Mark] Blah-blah.
No,
why is this an option now?!
No!
[Ominous voice] "Is that so?"
"Hmhmhm..."
[Nadine] "Morning!"
[Mark] Alright, let's...
...talk.
[Nadine] "Have you ever tried taking care of a pet?"
[Mark] They get scared of me.
[Nadine] "Oh..."
"...I don't think you're scary."
[Narration] "You talked to Nadine for a while."
"What do you have on your mind?"
[Mark] Maybe we could eat?
OOOH this is where it...
Oh.
This is - Oh!
Okay.
I'll "eat" you instead!
Which FOR SOME REASON causes you to blush...
Your eyes go star...
and a heart appear up in the top.
I'm assuming what each of those slots probably means another day in the week.
You're doing...
Eh, you're doing alright.
You're doing OK.
[Ominous voice] "Stop trying to be human."
"She smells... quite nice."
[Mark] Why is that monster shaped like a heart?
[Ominous voice] "Maybe even better than the last."
"Just a little flesh would be nice, wouldn't it?"
[Mark] WHADDYA TRYNA SAY THERE, BUDDY?
WHADDYA TRYNA SAY?
OHOHO!
No.
[Ominous voice] "Really, now?"
"Accept it..."
[Mark] I dunno what I'm supposed to be accepting!
I - I - I need food, so that'd be nice!
[Nadine] "Time to wake up and get moving!"
[Mark] FEED ME!
[Narration] "The menu for today is... pie."
[Nadine] "Home-made pie, to be exact! I made it myself, I hope you like it!"
[Mark] It tastes good.
Okay, I finished eating,
so that's a little bit better!
So maybe I'm not going to murder you!
[Nadine] "What should we do this afternoon?"
[Mark] Well we should probably play...
[Nadine] "So, um..."
"What do you usually play? I don't really know."
[Mark] VIDEO GAMES!
HELL YES!
[Nadine] "I see... Hm..."
[Narration] "Nadine pondered for a long while."
[Mark] Why - YOU PONDERED?
YOU DIDN'T GIVE ME A GOD-DAMN GAME?!
WHAT THE HECK?!
WHAT THE HECKY-HECK?!
[Nadine] "It's getting quite late, time to sleep!"
[Ominous voice] "Blood..."
"Doesn't that girl have it?"
[Mark] Goddammit-
NO!
[Nadine] "It's been a few days since I started taking care of you."
"...You weren't that bad of a monster."
[Mark] Are you falling for me?
[Nadine] "Ahaha, you dummy..."
(Mark laughs)
[Nadine] "Okay!" (chuckles) "Let's start the day with a bang!"
[Mark] Alright.
Let's...
PLAY!
[Narration] "Nadine brought--"
[Mark] OH! You brought vidya games!
[Nadine] "Hey, look! I'm sure you'll like it! It's a game where you roll this ball and..."
[Mark] I've played that before.
[Nadine] "Oh! In that case, will you give me some tips and tricks about it?"
[Narration] "You played along with Nadine for a bit."
[Mark] O-Ooh!
That's sweet~!
[Nadine] "Hmm... something to do, something to do..."
[Mark] Well, we could eat!
[Narration] "The menu today is soup."
[Nadine] "This... wouldn't really make you full, huh?"
[Mark] It's - IT'S SOMETHING!
I like soup!
Hey, I'm a soup kind of guy!
[Nadine] "Mhm, we should be content with what we are given!"
[Narration] "You finished eating and cleaned up."
[Nadine] "I'll be submitting some reports to the agency tonight."
"Have a good sleep!"
"I didn't get much sleep today..."
[Mark] Oh, do you just wanna sleep?
You want - You want to take a nap?
Wanna take a nap?
Take a nap!
(Repeating) Take a nap!
(Repeating again) Take a nap!
[Nadine] "I'll sing you a song while you nap."
[Mark] Oh!
[Narration] "You listened to Nadine as you slowly drifted to sleep."
[Nadine] "Any plans to do something?"
[Mark] Well, we should probably eat.
[Narration] "The menu for today is slime salad."
[Mark] Yay?
[Nadine] "...This... certainly looks quite appetizing..."
[Mark] I KNOW...
You should try it!
Try it!
C'mon, try it!
[Nadine] "Is this a thing really edible...?"
[Narration] "Nadine takes a bite."
[Ominous voice] "You didn't tell her that it's poi--"
[Mark] OH COME ON!
WHAT?!
WHAT THE FUCK?!
NO!
WHAT?!
WHAT -- ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
BULLSHIT ON THAT!
WHAT A LOAD OF ASS-DICKS!
Alright so what I'm gonna do,
there's gotta be a way to get hearts on every single one of them,
which is what I imagine's gonna be good.
At least I guess, maybe...
[Nadine] "Do you go to school?"
[Mark] OH,
PFFT!
TOO COOL FOR THAT!
Way too cool!
Heh!
[Nadine] "You do seem smart, after all."
[Mark] Hey...
Yeah, (chuckling)
Yeah!
Hell yeah I do!
[Nadine] "What should we do this afternoon?"
[Mark] Well I dunno.
You have something on Day 3, right?
Pie.
Ooh. It tastes good.
It tastes reeeal good...
[Narration] "Getting quite late, time to sleep!"
[Ominous voice] "You're doing better...!"
[Mark] Hey, I haven't even had a night urge to eat her!
I think I'm doing great!
Are you falling for me?
He-He-ey!
Ho-ho-ho-ho!
Yeah!
Alright, let's start this off with a BANG!
With...
Uh...
(Contemplative noise)
Talking?
[Nadine] "Hey, do you have any friends?"
[Mark] I'M A MONSTER!
I HAVE NO FRIENDS!
NOBODY WANTED ME,
NOBODY LIKED ME,
AND NOBODY WANTED TO BE NEAR ME!
Nobody wanted me...
[Nadine] "Really...? You seem like you would be a really good friend to have!"
[Narration] "You had a fun conversation with Nadine."
[Mark] Aw, that's lovely~!
[Nadine] "Hmm... something to do,"
[Mark] I'm guessing...
I...
need...
to...
...take... a nap!
Because that's what I need!
You have a needs thing in the top left,
So I'm assuming...
I'm gonna nip-nap the day away!
[Nadine] "I'll read you something as you sleep."
"Day One, Evening. A lady wearing white was sighted near my house. It was said that she..."
[Narration] "You pretended not to hear the story and fell asleep."
[Mark] Nice.
[Nadine] "I'll be submitting some reports to the agency tonight."
"Have a good sleep!"
[Narration] "You had a nice long sleep."
"You woke up feeling really great!"
[Nadine] "I didn't get much sleep today..."
[Mark] You wanna-
Do you wanna talk it out?
You wanna talk?
You wanna talk about it?
[Nadine] "So what are your hobbies?"
[Mark] NOT WANTING A CARETAK---
Cooking!
[Nadine] Wow,"
"I never thought you'd be into that! I'm a decent cook myself. Would you teach me?"
[Narration] "You conversed with Nadine as the hours go by."
[Nadine] "Any plans?"
[Mark] Let's eat!
No, let's...
PLAAY~
No, let's eat!
And this time, NOT...
You're not gonna get--
You're not gonna die.
I know.
[Nadine] "Let's have something else after this, shall we?"
[Mark] Aw, shit!
GODDAMMIT I was gonna end it on a good note!
[Nadine] "What a good day that was! Well, see you tomorrow!"
[Mark] (muttering) Well, it was going to be a good day...
[Nadine] "Wake up sunshine, all is well today!"
[Mark] Rea- Is it?
Is it really?
[Nadine] "Have you ever fallen in love?"
[Mark] "I've fallen for you."
[Nadine] "Oh, come on..."
[Narration] "You talked about love for some reason..."
[Mark] Who knows why...
A dot-du-dot...
[Nadine] "Ah, I'm a little tired..."
[Mark] Well then let's sleep!
Let's just sleepy-sleepy-sleep...
[Nadine] "Ah, sleeping early?"
"Well, sweet dreams."
[Mark] You too!
[Narration] "You took a nap, and felt something touch your cheek."
[Mark] Awoh! It's the blood from my ceiling...
Oh, it always flows and comforts me so much...
[Nadine] "So, um... tomorrow's our last day..."
[Mark] FINALLY! Ju-Just go!
I will miss you.
So much.
BABY!
[Nadine] "Anyways, I have to prepare for tomorrow, night night!"
[Narration] "You had a well-deserved rest."
[Ominous voice] "You're doing better than last time!"
[Mark] Supposedly...
[Nadine] "Morning! We should enjoy this moment as much as we can!"
[Mark] Hah!
Let's PLAY!
YAY!
[Narration] "Nadine brings a Rubik's Cube."
[Nadine] "Hey, ever tried to solve one of these?"
[Mark] Not really.
[Nadine] "I played this a lot when I was a kid, let me show you how a pro handles this!"
[Narration] "You played with Nadine for a long while."
[Mark] Dot dot. Dot dot dot dot.
[Narration] "Nadine's nowhere to be found."
"Has she left already...?"
[Mark] (muttering) Oh, no...
Dot dot dot.
[Narration] "You felt a presence behind you."
[Mark] AH!
OH! OH GOD!
[Nadine] "Sorry, I had to leave a little early."
"I, uh... went to the agency and..."
"Asked if I could... have an extension on ... being your caretaker..."
[Mark] Oh... Senpai...
[Nadine] "I've grown fond of you... and... well..."
"I wanted to spend time with you... more..."
[Mark] Oh.
Geez.
Well gosh.
Oh, Oh! OH GOD!
I LOVE YOU! I LOVE YOU SO MUCH!
I LOVE EVERYTHING ABOUT YOU!!
[Nadine] "M-Me too..."
[Mark] GREAT!
Oh, now I don't have to EAT you!
If you would have rejected me, I would have just gobbled you up right on the spot to save myself from the embarrassment!
Oh!
Why do I have nails-- (chuckling)
Do I have nails in my head?
And why am I blushing with the back of my skull?
Is that just where I radiate heat?
[Narration] "You hugged Nadine."
[Nadine] "A-ah!"
"What should we do today? Hee hee."
[Mark] AYYY! I guess that's the end! What the fuck?
Alright then! We did good. Maybe? I dunno.
Maybe that was good.
I-I'm gonna -- I'm gonna try to understand, and I'm gonna look up a little bit of a walkthrough to see if there was something else I could have done there.
Okay, so apparently there's a middle-of-the-road ending and that was the best ending. I DID IT!
I'm the master of love! No matter what I do I just fall in love where ever I go, except the real world because that's not... applicable...
Anyways, so, yeah! There's a middle-of-the-road ending and then there's a good ending - which is what we got - and the bad ending is when you eat her....
But maybe there's more out there, I'll put a link for the game in the description below and maybe you can try to find another ending.
It's pretty fun! I like it a lot! It's charming in a way.
And I believe this came from GameJam so,
Thank you everybody so much for watching,
let me know how I did down in the comments below.
And as always! I will see you- in the next video! BUH-BYE!
(outro music)
BUH-BYE! from the subtitle contributors :)